let's talk a little bit about the guns
that you guys chose to to use for this
so um you tell me that this is the beta
so there's just a couple that you have
well i mean this this screen is from the
start so we only had the basic like the
we got a sniper and an assault rifle and
an SMG yeah which is fine but like you
know we went through and you pick up
items and in attachments and weapons by
doing missions or going to a stronghold
looting their stuff or you can pick them
off the ground so by the end of it we
were all using different stuff but yeah
these are like the basic start not
balanced that's kind of great yeah so
these are the specialty weapons that you
can find on like the bosses around yeah
kill so they have specific weapons that
are fit is like their weapon specific to
them and then you can take it and use it
you can't customize them but you really
don't have to cuz look at it it's
perfect if you grab one of these guns is
it kind of like like adding an ear to
your necklace of yours yeah pretty much
exactly like cuz it goes it let you know
what mission that person is done when
you're playing in your stream looks like
oh I haven't got that guy in pipe cuz
you have not to beat this boss yet yeah
yeah oh that's cool so gives you a sort
of a sense if I kind of where you are in
the game and like where other people are
in the game it's a profi you know you
get for doing well you're like yeah
completed the service this area I mean
you can't like you said you can't
customize it so it is basically what you
see is what you get but for the weapons
you can customize like it's really
specific to the your type of play style
too cuz like for me I like to snipe and
sometimes talker just likes to go in
wild and get it is okay go where you
know with an LMG we incur we heard you
doing that earlier today sure yes sure
we have video of it is something I'm
sure okay and I think with all this
stuff you know like like go to the left
said that we need get a chance to
actually customize a weapon book as
we're watching right now you can see you
can change the stock of that gun you
could change the barrel of it which
gonna give you more accuracy or maybe
handle it better so I think that's
something that we'll all look forward to
when get the open game yeah believe it
or not it still doesn't help you become
that much better like if you're bad bad
bad
for Chanel bounty is someone who is
experienced at being bad at games III
feel that yeah I really really care
about anyone get close to home